Tief in Lappland, nahe der Stadt Rovaniemi,
liegt das Weihnachtsmanndorf - der Ort, an
dem der Weihnachtsmann wohnt.
Merry Christmas!
Aus der ganzen Welt kommen die
Besucher in den hohen Norden.
Seit 1985 empfängt der Weihnachtsmann
hier nämlich jedes Jahr tausende
Weihnachtsfans direkt in
seinem Wohnzimmer
und hört sich all ihre Wünsche an.
Hallo, ich bin der Weihnachtsmann, und
ich fühle mich ziemlich echt.
Wir sind hier am Polarkreis,
der das Tor zum Norden ist,
aber auch der Eingang zur Welt der
Märchen und Träume.
Ein wundervoller Ort, um sich
etwas zu wünschen.
Zweifel an der Existenz des
Weihnachtsmanns gibt es hier nicht.
Man ist niemals zu alt, um an den
Weihnachtsmann zu glauben.
Seit meiner Kindheit weiß ich, dass der
Weihnachtsmann Geschenke bringt.
Ich wollte mal sehen, ob es ihn wirklich gibt.
Der Weihnachtsmann spricht
sogar Portugiesisch.
Ja, ich glaube, er ist mehrsprachig
oder so ähnlich.
Nicht jeder kann persönlich beim
Weihnachtsmann vorbeischauen.
Deswegen kommen jedes Jahr
rund 500.000 Briefe,
Wunschzettel und Karten in
seinem offiziellen Postamt an.
Die ganze Post kann der Weihnachtsmann
natürlich nicht allein erledigen.
Fleißige Elfen greifen ihm
dabei unter die Arme.
Wir haben jeden Tag geöffnet,
das ganze Jahr lang.
Das hier ist ein normales finnisches Postamt.
Man kann Karten oder Päckchen verschicken
oder schöne Briefmarken kaufen.
Und natürlich kommen hier auch alle Briefe
an den Weihnachtsmann an.
Gern schicken die Besucher auch von hier
aus Karten mit Nordpolarkreisstempel
nach Hause an ihre Lieben.
Der Weihnachtsmann weiß jeden der an ihn
adressierten Briefe zu schätzen,
aber manche Post geht ihm besonders nah.
Manchmal bekomme ich Briefe,
in denen mir kleine Mädchen oder Jungs
schreiben, dass sie selbst alles haben,
aber etwas für eine andere Person erbitten,
weil die Person Hilfe braucht.
Diese Briefe sind mir besonders lieb.
Ein ganzer Themenpark
rund um Weihnachten:
Im Dorf des Weihnachtsmannes kann man
alles, was zur Adventszeit gehört,
an einem Tag erleben.
Seit 30 Jahren ist das Dorf bei Rovaniemi die
Pilgerstätte für Weihnachtsfans.
Der Legende nach liegt die wahre
Heimat des Geschenkebringers
aber noch viel höher im Norden.
Uns wurde immer erzählt,
dass der Weihnachtsmann
vom Korvatunturi kommt.
Das ist ein Berg, der wie ein Ohr geformt ist,
so dass der Weihnachtsmann die Wünsche
der Kinder aus aller Welt hören kann.
Aber dieser Ort ist sehr abgelegen,
nahe der finnisch-russischen Grenze.
Deshalb wurde das
Weihnachtsmanndorf hierher gebaut,
um es Reisenden leichter zu machen, den
Weihnachtsmann zu treffen.
Das Santa Claus Village ist zwar
das ganze Jahr über geöffnet,
im Winter aber besonders stimmungsvoll.
Bis zu minus 20 Grad Celsius
kalt wird es hier.
Perfekt, um ein paar Runden mit dem
Hundeschlitten zu drehen.
Mit den Rentieren geht es deutlich langsamer.
Wie schafft es der
Weihnachtsmann überhaupt,
so viele Kinder gleichzeitig zu beschenken?
Zeit ist relativ.
Und das ist es auch schon.
Man muss einfach wissen, wie man an
Millionen Orten gleichzeitig sein kann.
Nach jahrhundertelanger Übung
schaffe ich das ziemlich gut.
Abends wird es im Weihnachtsmanndorf
richtig gemütlich:
Lagerfeuer oder Musikshows -
hier erliegt auch der letzte Weihnachtsmuffel
dem Zauber des Festes.
Und alle, die ihn nicht besuchen können,
lässt der Weihnachtsmann schön grüßen.
Ich wünsche euch allen frohe Weihnachten.